Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, welcome back
to my season 4 countdown.
I wanted to talk about the Marathon HBO is
doing starting this Friday and provide some
extra alternatives in case you don’t get
HBO and you don’t want to ask your friends
for their HBO Go Password.
If they’re willing to give it to you they
deserve a high five.
For the rest of us there’s still a ton of
stuff to do like brushing up on the chapters
that the first couple of episodes will cover
and checking out that new Arya Winds of Winter
chapter george rr martin posted.
If you’re finding me for the first time
and are all like WTF Game of Thrones Countdown.
I’m just doing a couple extra videos to
get back into dragon mode.
Before episode 1 airs this sunday.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
More details about everything at the end of
the video and in the description.
(point down).
First let’s talk Marathon.
If you have access to HBO they’ll be doing
a 60 hour marathon starting on Friday.
They’re just airing everything from season
1 to season 3 back to back, twice.
With the last episode ending just before Season
4 episode 1 airs.
So you could potentially lock yourself in
a room and do nothing but watch it all weekend.
I would not advise doing that, but high fives
if you want to try.
For people who don’t have access to HBO
or if you don’t feel like re-watching everything
again there’s the books and expanded material.
Even though they’ve blended a lot of elements
from books 3 and 4 together already, here’s
which chapters to read or re-read before episode
1 on Sunday.
For Dany, you should start with Storm of Swords
chapter 42.
That ends right where season 3 ended.
If you want a preview of what Mereen is going
to be like you can skip ahead and read her
next POV chapter which is 57.
Thankfully most of her story the first part
of the season is still contained to book 3.
For Kings Landing Peoples it’s a little
trickier because Jaimie came back sooner than
he did in the books.
With the exception of him, almost everything
you need to re-read is also in book 3.
I would use Tyrion’s chapters as a guide.
Starting with chapter 53, if you want to re-read
the Red Wedding chapter and what follows go
all the way back to chapter 49.
Lots of reading I know.
So basically if you don’t want any spoilers
just stick to what’s between chapters 42
and 53.
Don’t read past that because there’s a
Jon Snow chapter with some spoilery stuff.
If you don’t feel like reading the books
then I’d recommend buying the card game
or one of the awesome 3D puzzles.
I’m actually going to Geek and Sundry’s
Tabletop Day on saturday, so I’m hoping
to find some people playing the card game
there.
If you live in los angeles I think there’s
still tickets available.
They include hot dogs and beer.
You have to be over 13 to get in though.
Because booze.
Obviously 21 to partake.
But there will be tons of games.
Here’s all my social links, I’ll be posting
pictures and videos to instagram and twitter
throughout the day.
I’ll also post the tickets link for that
in the comments below.
In related news I’ll probably have time
for about two more bonus Game of Thrones videos
before Sunday, so let me know what you want
to see in those.
When it does come back I’ll be doing Sunday
reviews and monday Q&A’s just like for Walking
Dead.
Since a lot of international people said they
don’t get to watch episodes till the next
day after people in the US I might do two
giveaways or split it up somehow with a Tuesday
Video.
Let me know when Game of Thrones airs in your
country so I can figure it out.
Right now click here for the rest of my countdown
videos and click here for the last trailer.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!